bah
puis de quatre mille collégiens des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine se sont
rendus au château de versailles pour
découvrir le château et son histoire
gens à contacter long des arts au
programme arts de la scène arts visuels
numériques architecture ou encore
littérature l'académie de versailles
recrute elle a organisé un job dating
destination des demandeurs d'emploi des
personnes en reconversion ou des
étudiants en fin d'études
objectif compléter ses effectifs et
préparer la rentrée prochaine plus de
400 postes sont à pourvoir dans les
yvelines le maire de vitres jean
baptiste à monique et le maire de port
marly cédric panda marines ont lancé un
partenariat visant à récolter des fonds
pour l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque
ils veulent récolter 24000 euros pour
permettre des enfants cardiaques d'être
opéré en france et accueillis dans des
familles des deux communes la seconde
édition des assises du numérique
organisé par seine et yvelines
numériques le département des yvelines
et les hauts de seine a élu aux
pyramides de port marly tables rondes et
ateliers autour des différents enjeux du
numérique étaient organisées tout au
long de la journée
placée sous la responsabilité du château
de versailles depuis 2019 le domaine
national de marly le roi a été reconnu
le jardin remarquable par le ministère
de la culture une labellisation qui
récompense le patrimoine historique et
environnemental
admirable qu'il représente
[Musique]
pas